[Música]
ah
buenas tardes para mí es un gusto
compartir con ustedes va a ser para mí
un poco difícil el mantenerme acá porque
soy una mujer absolutamente inquieta y
solo moverme de un lado a otro pero
bueno voy a tratar de mantenerme
quiero comenzar contándoles que siempre
he sido una mujer muy inquieta desde
niña
he vivido en un hogar en el que el
cuidado el amor la valoración siempre
estado presente pero también en un hogar
que tenía la tradición bien marcada
tengo 50 años y cuando yo era niña la
tradición era que tú tenías que ser
virgen la tradición era que tenías que
cazar y habían muchas tradiciones
cuando era niña y hasta ahora creo
siempre había sido guayaquil saben lo
que es lo adquirí verdad si no corta o
así cualquier y es aquella persona que
le interesa estudiar se va estudiando no
necesita jalar el saco eso lo hacen los
corchos
y pasaba muy bien mi infancia hasta que
a mis 8 años recuerdo que estaba en el
colegio un día estaba haciendo un regalo
para el día de la madre porque les
hacíamos nosotros no los contábamos
estaba haciendo un regalo con un
cucharón y llegó la hora de recreo y
todos todas salieron
menos yo que me quería ser el regalo
cuando termino yo creo volvieron mis
compañeras y una de ellas dijo se han
perdido me escucharon
alguien me ha robado me escucharon
y la profesora me pregunto dijo quién se
quedó
tú eres la ladrona
y me agarró del brazo y me llevó a
dirección
recuerdo yo la directora era una
francesa muy linda le dijo y por qué le
dices eso le has preguntado no pero es
que ella se quedó no había otra
posibilidad
y yo recuerdo que yo grabar
avergonzada
a mis 8 años en ese sentido en carencia
con este vacío que uno no puede llenar
en eso llegó mi compañera y dijo
encontramos el cucharón
y la profesora dijo vamos al aula
nunca me dijo qué
lo siento
a mis ocho años yo juré nunca ser
maestra
y así pasó el tiempo seguí siendo huesca
y fue una de las mejores estudiantes en
el colegio salí y en el último año
cuando estábamos por salir vinieron las
pruebas vocacionales
me hicieron las pruebas vocacionales y
me salieron tres carreras
saben cuál es
pedagogía
psicología y trabajo social me acerque
al psicólogo y le dije pedagogía es ser
maestro si me dijo no quiero eso
psicóloga
ya además siempre había escuchado a mis
compañeras también quiero ser psicóloga
al poco tiempo de eso finalizando
secundaria tenía 17 años y en una fiesta
vivió un abuso sexual
el momento en que yo viví este abuso
como mucha gente quise matarlo lo
primero todavía tengo algún recuerdo por
aquí como ven no me muerto
me tome algunas pastillas tampoco
memoria
por algo tenía que ser
y ahí dije sí psicología
la mejor carrera
así resuelvo mi rollo sin tener que
contar un habla nada
como la mayor parte de los psicólogos
entramos a la carrera tratando de
resolver nuestros rollos sin tener que
contar nada a nadie
terminé la carrera
y supe que tenía nomás que encontrar a
alguien que un psicólogo que no hace
terapia que es un buen psicólogo
entonces entre un proceso terapéutico
muy jovencitas de aquí de la católica
tenía 24 años y fui directo a trabajar
saben dónde a la cárcel de san pedro
y trabajando en la cárcel yo me encontré
con hombres que habían abusado
sexualmente de otros niños niñas pero
también tuve la oportunidad de escuchar
sus vidas
y de entender que estas personas no eran
marcianos malditos que habían caído aquí
a la tierra sino que también habían unas
historias bien duras ahí atrás
al poco tiempo de eso mi compañero
todavía lo recuerdo un sacerdote me
invitó a ser psicóloga de la normal
católica boliviana
yo muy orgullosa me fui y estuve
trabajando un año escuchando a la gente
escuchando a jóvenes como ustedes con
todos sus rollos y problemas
me invitaron a dar un taller
el taller era de relaciones
interpersonales
genial y de un taller de otro taller de
un tercer taller
ya era catedrático
y recuerdo que en una ceremonia en la
que estaban los estudiantes en medio de
la ceremonia uno de ellos dijo
gracias por darnos una profe como la
marines
yo soy rando escuche profe
yo soy profe
yo pensé que era psicóloga dando
talleres
y dije soy profe y hay un estudiante que
agradecido por mí y ha pedido que hayan
otros profes como yo en bolivia
y en ese momento rompí mi juramento de
niños porque dije lo que más amo en la
vida es ser profe
lo que más creo en la vida es que la
educación cambia y es a través de la
educación que podemos cambiar
michelle profe y ahora psicóloga me hice
propio
al tiempo de ello iba a defender mi
tesis no pude hacer mi tesis de
licenciatura en sexualidad porque hace
25 años atrás aquí no podías hacer tesis
de sexualidad mucho menos cualitativa
pero hice una tesis que se llamó la
importancia de las relaciones
interpersonales entre maestro y
estudiantes para el aprendizaje
significativo
años después me di cuenta que era mi
rollo que había proyectado en mi tesis
y seguía con la inquietud
de poder trabajar con nuestra comunidad
para que no hayan más niños más niñas
para que no hayan más jóvenes que vivan
abusos sexuales
y entonces me fui a trabajar al
ministerio de educación como consultora
trabajaba en interculturalidad en
educación en pedagogía trabajaba
y todo lo que tenía que ver con la
educación de nuestro país pero siempre
estaba metida en los temas de sexualidad
siempre
para ese momento se llamaba transversal
de sexualidad y ahí estaba metida yo
y en medio del trabajo en que iba
haciendo dije qué pasa con la gente
porque le tiene tanto miedo a la
sexualidad
porque se mueve en el morbo y el tabú
pues hay que hacer caer eso
el tabú aquello que no se dice nos hace
daño porque como familias no podemos
ayudar a que nuestros niños niñas
conozcan su cuerpo su vida su sexualidad
lo valoren
pero el morbo nos hacen más daño todavía
porque nos hace creer que la pornografía
es libertad
algo hay que hacer y entonces dije
tengo que seguir mi formando y ahí entré
a la especialidad en sexualidad
la academia tenía que servir para algo
no solamente para ganar notas tenía que
ponerse al servicio de la comunidad
pero esto no me no es suficiente porque
tenía que conocer porque en nuestro país
no se hacían políticas públicas que
ayuden a la gente
para prevenir violencias sexuales y
entonces decidí ahí hacer la maestría en
filosofía y ciencia política
fue interesante porque mi tesis saben
que se llama
descolonización desde el aula
seguía arrastrando creo a la profesora
vez
de 3º de primaria
pero seguía trabajando para que desde la
academia desde adentro de la academia
movamos generemos revolución generemos
cambio y sabía que podíamos hacerlo
mucho más en temas de sexualidad
yo no quería ser la bomba sexy de la
sexualidad quería ser la educadora en
sexualidad
y a partir de ello habría una
institución una institución para
trabajar en sexualidad en educación en
psicología en comunicación
y por ello apareció la posibilidad de
hacer un programa un programa de
televisión que mucha gente lo conoce se
llama comunidad sexual
este programa parte de la idea de que
todos somos sexuados no hay persona
sexuada y todos somos una comunidad
sexual y entre todos podemos prevenir
violencias entre todos podemos cambiar
esta situación
trabajé muchos años
y sigo trabajando en comunidad sexual
pero me seguía faltando algo
y seguía faltando coronar aquello que
era importante para mi educación y eso
me llevó a hacer el doctorado en
educación
y metáis saben en qué era
educación para la sexualidad así se
llama mi tesis
y seguir trabajando
y ahora me encuentro con muchas personas
jóvenes como ustedes algunas mayores
que dicen yo he vivido un abuso sexual
y nunca lo he dicho
y no lo he dicho porque me da vergüenza
y entonces trabajo para que la gente
sepa qué vergüenza debería sentir la
persona que ha tocado la persona que ha
manoseado la persona que ha manipulado
la persona que ha violado no quién ha
vivido esa situación
y entonces seguí trabajando en terapia
pero las violencias nos han seguido
avasallando y entonces hay que trabajar
contra la violencia
pero para ello hay que generar
encuentros y hay que investigar
ahí estaba nuestro amigo de la
investigación
y por eso ahora estoy en un
postdoctorado de investigación
cuando me invitaron los compañeros
compañeras de aquí de la universidad
para encontrarme con ustedes yo dije qué
voy a hacer voy a llegar como iniciarlas
y voy a decir quién tuvo sexo anoche
levante la mano
y sé que la gente va a decir yo no
estaba mi pareja y yo le voy a decir no
confundas sexo con coito no es lo mismo
pero es este mundo que nos avasalla a
este mundo tan pornográfico que nos hace
pensar que el coito y el sexo son lo
mismo y por eso no hacemos una buena
educación para la sexualidad
pero ellos me explicaron y me dijeron no
puedes dar tu charla de sexualidad para
otro momento comparte con nosotros que
te hizo la doctora de la sexualidad
que me hizo la doctora de la sexualidad
las carencias
qué es una carencia cada vez que tú te
sientes vacío
cada vez que tú sientes que porque te
han pegado te han robado que han
abandonado o lo que sea que haya pasado
en tu vida te quedas así vacío en cero
ahí tienes dos posibilidades desde mi
experiencia quedarte en carencia y
victimizarse y decir sí a mí mi papá no
me hubiera abandonado yo sería el mejor
estudiante de la universidad
si a mí no me hubieran robado yo tendría
un importe si a mí no me hubieran etc
o pasar de este lugar de víctima porque
todos y todas hemos sido víctimas
hemos estado en carencia en algún
momento o pasar de este lugar de víctima
al lugar de sobreviviente a la situación
que has vivido
cuando sobrevives esta situación dura
entonces vas a pasar al lugar de
facilitador y ahí vas a hacer lo que han
hecho todos mis compañeros que me han
antecedido ustedes creen que eso ha sido
casual ha sido casual que nuestro amigo
esté tratando de reivindicar los
alimentos bolivianos les aseguro que no
que todos hemos partido de una carencia
pero hemos hecho potencia de esta
carencia
yo les invito a ello
nos hemos acostumbrado a quejarnos por
eso programas como proteste ya
tiene tanto éxito hay pocos que dicen
propongan
y hay pocos que dicen hágalo ya
pasen de la carencia a la potencia
que aquello que ha sido basura en su
vida
se convierta en abono
se puede de verdad se pues gracias
[Aplausos]